yeah i feel like a loser you know
kim kardashian is getting candid about
how she's feeling about her divorce from
kanye west
in the mid-season trailer for keeping up
with the kardashians final season
the beauty mogul got highly emotional in
front of her family
appearing to be speaking about the split
yeah i feel like a
loser you know i just want you to be
happy and joyful
yeah and i'm ready too last month a
source told et
the reality star is adjusting to her new
life amid her divorce from the rapper
sharing that kim has been doing her best
to surround herself with her family and
good friends
be social go out and take care of her
children
quote she is focused on making sure her
kids are taken care of and protected
but she is definitely still getting used
to her new norm
it's a different experience for sure
meanwhile
also in the new tease kim is weighing in
on her sister courtney's relationship
with her
ex and the father of her three kids
scott disick
think about all the times he's had big
change hasn't been positive for him
the former couple goes on to have an
intense conversation about their
relationship while lying in bed together
i'm not going to be made to feel guilty
when
the things that i've asked of you
haven't been done
in the latest episode of keeping up with
the kardashians scott admitted he gets
super jealous when court dates other
people
i feel like it annoys me like when you
flirt with this lifeguard
i'm definitely not flirting with the
lifeguard all right maybe it's just
in my head like seeing you around any
guy
bothers me around another human that i'm
not flirting with
maybe it's just something i don't know i
feel like you're like a little flirty or
you're like i'm not
i promise then it's my insecurity then i
feel like that i just
don't like seeing you with another guy
it hurt me when you're with somebody
else scott is currently dating 19 year
old model amelia hamlin
and courtney is getting very serious
with blink 182 drummer travis barker
such a dream come true a source told e.t
last month that scott was still getting
used to her new
and very public relationship with the
musician
and while the co-parents are still very
close the source adds that their
relationship
is different now quote having courtney
and travis get
so serious has been an adjustment for
scott he is still trying to get used to
it
scott is still close with courtney but
things between them have
changed a bit the two have been able to
maintain a friendship and co-parent
together over the years
and that is something scott opened up to
et about back in 2019.
i mean i think you just got to figure
out really what's important to you at
the end of the day
at the end of the day i mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
you want to be comfortable a source told
et last month that court and travis's
relationship
is getting stronger quote travis is so
in love and infatuated with courtney
they're having the best time together
he's 100
all in and totally sees a future with
her courtney
is living her best life and is truly so
[Music]
happy